pour en parler nous sommes avec dave
king membre du conseil d'administration
des communautés unis contre la brutalité
policière bonsoir dave vikings merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vous vivez à minneapolis non loin de
l'endroit où djordje floyd a été
interpellés depuis une semaine
telle est l'atmosphère dans la ville on
ressent enfin en tout cas depuis la
france que les choses ne s'apaise pas
nord effectivement les choses ne
s'apaisent pas et elle ne s'appelle
seront sans doute pas rapidement les
gens sur place ne sont pas satisfaits
par les paroles apaisantes de certains
hommes politiques car il est sans doute
déjà entendu et rien n'a changé alors
effectivement on le disait minneapolis
qui est devenu l'épicentre de la
protestation contre justement ces
violences policières guette il davantage
les inégalités dans cette ville que dans
d'autres villes du pays au sein des
états unis mia police connaît les pires
statistiques s'agissant des disparités
entre blancs et noirs et autres
personnes de couleur en matière
d'éducation de logement et bien sûr de
brutalité policière
et cette tendance dure depuis plusieurs
années mais les mêmes conditions
existent dans la plupart des villes des
états unis et même ailleurs c'est
pourquoi ce soulèvement s'est propagé à
d'autres villes où on connaît la même
chose les personnes de couleur amis à
police savait que les conditions n'ont
pas changé et le voit dans la rue les
policiers les traitent mal à tous les
jours donc cela va continuer nous sommes
pas unique mais il avons effectivement
des problèmes très spéciaux ici qui ont
mené à ces situations
beaucoup d'observateurs ont parlé de
racisme ancrée
aux états unis on imagine que c'est
votre avis on l'accomplît dans vos
propos comment vous vous l'expliquer les
gens sont en colère et j'en suis très en
colère ils ont été traités de manière
horrible pendant très longtemps et ce en
est la conséquence les gens sont sous
payés il ya beaucoup de chômage beaucoup
de sdf
cela est une source de colère bien sûr
il ya des opportunistes également qu'ils
rejoignaient le mouvement
mais ce que l'on peut constater
notamment c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
solidarité entre les gens les
communautés viennent en nombre aux
manifestations et le voisinage essaye de
faire le ménage après le passage des
manifestants afin de survivre et la
police ne fait rien pour protéger les
individus la police attaque surtout des
manifestants pacifiques et n'être
personne d'autre au cours des nues face
et il y avait des moments où on ne
pourrait pas même espérer l'arrivée d'un
camion de pompier mais déjà on essaye de
défendre leur propre maison et la police
les attaques
comment vous nous expliquer justement ce
divorce entre guillemets entre la
population et la police qui est supposé
protéger cette population beaucoup de
belles paroles l'on parle beaucoup des
relations entre la communauté et la
police mais ce n'est que du blabla
après les meurtres précédent ait eu
beaucoup de paroles sur ce qu'il fallait
faire et comme
l'action était terrible on a demandé des
changements notre organisation a demandé
des changements des sanctions et la
modification de la culture au sein du
département de police
nous avons été complètement ignorés
parce qu'on est à souligner certains
problèmes personne au conseil municipal
au niveau du maire n'était prêt à réagir
le statu quo est très confortable pour
beaucoup de personnes et il est
bénéficie également à un petit nombre de
personnes
donc les choses ne vont pas changer
jusqu'à ce que les gens décident de
prendre la situation en main et j'espère
au vu de la réaction à ces événements
récents qu'il y aura enfin des
changements
vous parliez tout à l'heure des paroles
apaisantes de certains politiques
évidemment nous on entend depuis la
france surtout celle de donald femme qui
n'a rien d'apaisant tu donald trump
voilà qui se passe du côté de l'ordre
qui veut faire intervenir l'armée est ce
que sa voix pèse beaucoup aujourd'hui
aux états unis
dans cette situation de violence a
quasiment aucune influence a mis la
police ou dans les grandes villes il le
fait des déclarations terrifiante
certaines de ces propositions sont
absolument terrifiantes
oui mais le problème a mis la police ce
n'est pas notre appui n'y a pas deux
républicain à minneapolis
le problème ce sont les autorités
locales qui sont censés être libéral
avec le département de police un
département qui défend le statu quo et
le contrôle de la population
m effectivement est une source
d'inquiétude mais c'est vraiment le
moindre de nos problèmes
aujourd'hui selon vous les etats-unis
sont-ils un tournant on sortait comme
nous d'ailleurs de cette crise du
comique 19 qui a mis beaucoup de gens
sur le carreau il ya beaucoup de de
chômage
évidemment
or mais ces violences est ce que c'est
une phase il y aura un avant et un après
selon vous c'est certainement un
tournant
le virus effectivement accru les
divisions entre les personnes et j'en
suis certain cela contribue à la colère
dans les rues chômage et les systèmes de
santé ne sont pas du tout ego équitable
aux états unis après cette étincelle
après l'étincelle qui a représenté ce
meurtre terrible de la police on ne voit
pas souvent des vidéos de la sorte
lucas après c'était un sel il est
impossible de repartir en arrière on ne
peut pas se contrôler la situation
il faut que quelque chose craquer et
j'espère que nous sommes effectivement
un tournant de l'histoire des états unis
il le faut merci beaucoup des vikings
membres du conseil d'administration des
communautés unis contre la brutalité
policière merci d'avoir été avec nous
depuis mi-mai à police